it's time to talk about the lead doctor
again so I've been thinking a bit more
as I am want to do about Doctor Who and
specifically about the upcoming Jody
Whitaker's time as the doctor which I am
looking forward to I have concerns I
always have there are pitfalls that they
could fall into I hope that they avoid
them
but I want to talk kind of in regards to
one kind of specific aspect and
something that I really vehement ly hope
that they don't do I don't want them to
bring up the fact of the doctor change
gender very much at all as little as
possible like never if they can help it
like the extent to which I would like to
see the doctors gender change addressed
in the show itself would be basically
maybe having a character who's met the
doctor for go you're a woman now and the
doctors go so and gets back to whatever
the heck is going on that's kind of all
I want it to be and I know that's this
is a little bit of a change from
something I said over three years ago
now back when I said if they're gonna do
this there should be a narrative or
character driven reason they should
really dig in to explore why this is
happening I did feel that at the time
and I know some people still do I kind
of don't anymore and here's the main
reason why which is that the show itself
at this point doesn't need to make a big
deal out of the doctor being a woman
because we already have the culture as a
whole has made a big deal out of it so
to do it again in the show first of all
just kind of feels redundant it would
feel odd taking up story and character
space with addressing something that has
been the ongoing pop culture discussion
amongst Doctor Who fandom since July of
last year so it'll have been for over a
year by the time we start getting
episodes with her
so to start addressing that directly
would feel like it would almost feel
regressive would it feel like God didn't
we already deal with this and in terms
of the show directly and in episodes
well no but we have been dealing with it
as a culture and as a fandom long enough
and loudly enough that I I think the
best statement that they could make
would be no statement just let it be
just have her there being the doctor in
you know with her own nuances every
version of the doctor has had its own
nuances so I mean I'm not saying she has
to do it exactly the way anyone else did
it but not just don't bring it up the
change happen it's the thing that
happened why do we have to bog anything
down with that and again I know that
there are some people who really feel
that this needs to be justified in some
way like there needs to be some
explanation as to why this happened I've
seen even just just from my own comments
section all sorts of things get thrown
out everything from I think you know
Bill's tier somehow affected the doctor
and that's why it's gonna become a woman
I've seen people say that they think
because of seeing the more misogynistic
tendencies of the first doctor in twice
upon a time maybe the doctor want to be
a woman more and things like that and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
these theories I'm certainly not going
you're wrong for thinking that and it's
fine if that's your head can and go with
it I just I think there are better uses
of the show's time than to actually eat
up time addressing that stuff
specifically because basically what they
be doing is they would be making
responses to arguments from over a year
ago anything that they do in the show
that's like and this is why the doctor
is a woman now first of all is not going
to actually quell anyone who is not okay
with the doctor being a woman nothing
that you do is actually going to quell
people who are fundamentally not okay
with it
so all you're doing is this weird
retrograde thing where you do like an
official response to an argument that
feels like it should be winding down
instead of heating up again and in
general
I just think that about as much emphasis
should be put on the fact that the
doctor is now a woman as was previously
put on the fact that the doctor was a
man which is to say virtually none even
going back into the classic era there
are not a lot of stories where the fact
that the doctor is male actually has
direct influence on the narrative or is
even like touched upon as a thing to
talk about it did not happen very often
and I don't think it should happen very
often now that we've done the opposite
because then you just spend the entire
time she's there repeatedly trying to
justify the decision you made look the
decision was made some people didn't
like it some people will never like it
some people may turn around on it we'll
see but you're not gonna tell any good
stories if you're eating up all your
time and you keep coming back to trying
to justify it a decision that was
already made and already had its impact
it would have been like having Colin
Baker's doctor constantly keep bringing
up why it is he's wearing this huge
massive colorful coat which again is
something I hate but taking time out of
stories to justify it would not have
made it any better although that said I
guess Matt Smith did continually
justified like wearing a bowtie Oh God
look Christian Bell if you even had an
inkling to do a joke of like oh I've got
boobs now boobs are cool don't please
don't
and that's another sort of thing I feel
like at this point we need to just roll
with the idea that gender doesn't have a
ton of meaning within Timelord Society
now that's not saying that it has
absolutely no meaning to the doctor he
seems to understand gender well enough
as far as it is a distinction for his
companions if nothing else so it's not
like he's above gender or whatever but I
think at this point it's just best to
start rolling with the idea that they
don't get hung up on it like as a
species it's just it's it's like being
blonde or brunette why are you making a
big deal out of that because what I'm
really looking forward to what I'm
really excited to see is not how is a
woman doctor going to be rather than
just how is the nude
dr. going to be I would be equally as
excited and interest if they cast a man
if they catch anybody I want to see
what's next I don't need to see what's
next for a woman I don't care at this
point look I'm in I'm not going away
like I said I've got concerns I've got
reservations I'm not gonna pretend like
they vanished into nothing but my
enthusiasm is growing and largely
overshadowing my concerns and my
enthusiasm is for just finding out the
kinds of adventures we get the kind of
chemistry that she's gonna have with her
companions what kind of villains is she
got to face what kind of planets is she
gonna go to what's the sonic screwdriver
look like I don't really care how being
a woman changes her and I kind of think
it shouldn't because the more that you
decide that oh the doctor being a woman
means so much changes the more
importance you assign to gender and I'm
not saying that in our society gender
isn't important but again we see the the
whole thing seems to be leaning towards
it's not particularly important to the
Timelords
so that's us imposing something and
importance onto a character when it's
not important to them and that just
seems like a waste of energy a waste of
emphasis I don't think it's necessary
for the doctor to become a crusader for
women's causes not that I'm saying it
should be avoided either the doctor
should be a crusader for justice as the
doctor has always been in every
incarnation but I don't think that it is
necessary for the doctor to suddenly
become distinctly feminine icon in a way
that is different from how the character
has been portrayed before because I
think just the fact that the doctor is a
woman now isn't it says it that is
enough I personally am not particularly
interested in how the doctor being a
woman changes the doctor I am kind of
curious to see how the doctor
impacts and continues to impact the
fandom cuz that's uh an interesting case
study of nothing else but just having it
even if you feel that it is important to
make a statement just having her there
in this role as the doctor not a
companion not another Time Lord the
doctor that's a statement that's a big
one I think it's one that says plenty on
its own and piling more onto that won't
help so those are just sort of my
general current thoughts on where I hope
they don't go in terms of Jody what
occurs time as the doctor cuz yeah I'm
I'm I'm about as excited for this as I
usually am for new doctor stuff which is
nervously excited I am excited to see
what it is but I'm nervous to see what
it is cuz I I want it to be good as I
did when Matt Smith was cast as I did
when Capaldi was cast I am always going
to be nervous regardless of who it is
but I love the doctor as a character in
the fundamentals and I love the
adventures that the doctor goes on I
just want to see what are the character
traits of this version of the doctor
that get emphasized what are the
adventures that she goes on I don't need
things to keep and keep giving answers
and responses to criticism that will be
over a year old so those are my thoughts
on Jodie Whittaker the doctor how I kind
of hope things play out Loki is the
short version at least as far as
emphasis on the gender goes what are
your thoughts on this whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do all those things
like subscribe and I got Twitter and two
podcasts and emails and ID there's links
for everything down below and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]